welcome to 3abn today Bible q a I'm your
host JD Quinn let me introduce our three
abian family real quick this is Shelly
Quinn this is beautiful Shelley Quinn
who you're gaining points honey
we just want to thank you so much for
your questions we have the privilege of
studying to answer your questions and we
all learn each time we're learning
something we learn from each other it's
a a beautiful thing to study God's word
amen amen and we have our very handsome
John Dinsey
thank you for the encouragement I am
blessed to be here and it's a blessing
to study God's word and we really depend
on the Holy Spirit to help us answer
these questions amen amen and my good
friend Daniel Perrin that's right and I
occasionally have the privilege of being
on this program but when I'm not I have
an equal privilege of answering the
prayer calls and it's always a pleasure
and a privilege to pray with you when
you call here amen amen and question and
answers that's what this program is all
about how do we get these questions they
come from you and there's three ways
that we receive these questions from you
and that is by text by email and by
Instagram so let me mention to you how
we can receive it by text so if you have
questions most everybody has questions
well then you might take these these
Avenues down to text
618-228-3975 I think you'll see it on
your screen there
and if you're going to send it by email
it's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
and if you're going to use Instagram
it's at 3abn
underscore official
amen amen let's have prayer okay
fathers we come to you in the name of
Jesus thank you Lord for this
opportunity that we have that you've
given us your father to share you so
father I just asked Lord that as we
invite the Holy Spirit into our hearts
and to our minds dear father and to
those that are watching Lord that their
hearts will be touched their questions
will be answered we'll give you all
praise and glory in the name of Jesus
amen amen I have to say when you said to
share you that's what we're doing to
share the word word is to share him
that's beautiful amen amen thank you
we've got 12 questions
four four three into twelve is four so
each one of you going to have four
questions okay uh three of them are
going to be three minutes long
one will be four minutes long and so
we're going to start with uh Daniel
your first question
can you please explain the meaning of
the Book of Joel okay
I certainly can begin to try any book of
the Bible in four minutes is going to be
a challenge so let me give you the short
answer here the Book of Joel is about
Jesus because every book of the Bible
every page of the Bible points us to him
in Salvation through Jesus
so the Book of Joel the short answer is
look back at the past and see what God
has done particularly in dealing with
sin in your life and then look forward
to see what God is going to do dealing
with sin in the future which prompts you
right now to make a decision to allow
God to search your life and fill you
with his spirit so that you can be ready
when he comes now is the moment of
decision in the Book of Joel there's no
specific time period mentioned it simply
is built off of themes from the other
books of the Bible many different
phrases taken from other books of the
Bible and so it expects you to know
expects us to know what's written in the
rest of God's word there's also no
specific sins that are mentioned in the
Book of Joel it assumes that you and I
know what God is revealing in our hearts
that needs to be dealt with and so
through the reading of God's word we
allow him to investigate our life
chapter one takes you to the Past says
look at what God has done in the past
and there is a plague that apparently
has come in the past and that leads us
to allow God to examine Our Lives verse
14 of chapter 1 then says consecrate a
fast call a sacred assembly gather the
elders and all the inhabitants of the
land into the house the Lord your God
and cry out to the Lord for alas the day
of the Lord is at hand and it shall come
as destruction from the almighty and in
verse 16 the next verse it appears that
God's people his church is about to fall
chapter of 2 then turns us to the Future
it says blow the trumpet in Zion and
sound an alarm in my Holy Mountain I'd
be in the church let all the inhabitants
of the land tremble for the day of the
Lord is coming for it is at hand and so
once again look into the future we
realize that the past reveals it repeats
itself sin and apostasy still exists
we're not safe yet judgment is waiting
and there is there is something coming
on the horizon and so then this verse
gives us some Cosmic imagery of a
judgment and verse 11 of chapter 2 says
again for the day of the Lord is great
and very terrible who can endure it
who can endure it it's only the ones
that God empowers through his Spirit God
responds to the people there's always
hope in God's word chapter 2 down there
at verse 28 says and it shall come to
pass afterward that I will pour out my
spirit on All Flesh your sons and your
daughters shall prophesy your old men
shall dream dreams your young men shall
see visions and also on my man's
servants and my maidservants I will pour
out my spirit in those days there is
still hope because God says regardless
of what's happened in the past and
what's coming in the future my spirit
offered to you today is a way to have
your heart changed to have the sins
removed from your life as you allow me
to reveal them in Jesus then to cover
those sins there's a final judgment
coming chapter 3 deals with the Judgment
of the Nations there's two outcomes and
so we see that in verse 13 that says put
in the sickle for the Harvest is ripe
and that means right now we have a
choice to make verse 14 then says
multitudes multitudes in the valley of
decision that might be you it is you and
it is me too as God is constantly
inviting us to make a choice for the day
of the Lord is near in the valley of
decision verse 16 then says but the Lord
will be a shelter for his people and the
strength of the children of Israel and
so this is the story of Joel look at the
past and see what God's done and for you
in the past how he's worked help you to
free you of sin look at the future and
what's coming and make a choice for him
today because Jesus is the one verse 21
last verse says I will acquit them of
the guilt of Bloodshed whom I had not
acquitted for the Lord dwells in Zion
don't waste time says Joel make a
decision for Jesus today amen amen very
good
again Johnny yes sir your three-minute
question your number one question why
did Jesus cast the unclean spirits into
a herd of swine
and Ryan sends that in
okay very good and so Ryan this is from
Matthew chapter eight I'm going to go
ahead and read that really quick so that
those that don't know where that is can
get a picture of what's going on here it
begins in verse 28 and when he had come
to the other side to the country of the
gergisines
there met him two demon-possessed men
coming out of the tombs exceedingly
Fierce so that no one could pass that
way and suddenly they cried out saying
what have we to do with you Jesus you
Son of God have you come here to torment
us before the time now a good way off
from there there was a herd of many
swine feeding so the demons begged him
saying if you cast us out permit us to
go into the herd of swine and he said to
them go so when they had come out they
went into the herd of swine and suddenly
the whole herd of swine ran violently
down violently down the Steep Place into
the sea and perished in the water so
this is uh where this is taken from and
the question is why did Jesus do this
uh he did it for the sake of those that
were in the area and also to bring a
rebuke to the Jews that were doing
something they were not supposed to do
what were they doing they were raising
swine and to the Jews and to those the
these are unclean animals as identified
in Leviticus chapter 11. they are still
unclean today by the way so this is not
something that has been cleansed and so
these Jews were dealing in making money
making Market out of race and Swine they
were not supposed to do this and the
demons as Jesus send us there of course
there was a bad intention in this
because the demons wanted to get Jesus
out of there and it seems to have worked
but Jesus had a reason for why he did
this and so the swine went down and they
all perished and so these people
thinking we lost a lot of money here all
of the potential gain we could have had
from these are gone so now they wanted
Jesus out but this is a rebuke to them
but Jesus in getting these swine and the
demons out of there was also a good
lesson and also uh Jesus knew what was
going to happen What were the demons
doing there they were there to cause
harm
and so
he potentially saved the people from
being tormented and from uh potentially
being hurt themselves by the demons so
this was a a several things were taking
place here
amen amen good answer right answer
Shelley your three-minute question
number one Proverbs 16 5 everyone who is
proud in heart is an Abomination to the
Lord assuredly he will not be unpunished
does this mean I shouldn't be proud when
I do something you know like getting
good grades or drawing a cool picture
and this is from Joshua
Joshua I so appreciate you let's read
that again Proverbs 16 5 everyone who is
proud and heart is the Abomination to
the Lord
assuredly he will not go unpunished what
the Bible saying the word there for
proud is to be high-minded to be haughty
to be arrogant to be bragging
and I'm just going to tell you it is
natural for you to be happy when you
make an achievement to be happy you make
good grades it's natural for you to be
happy when you draw a cool picture but
just don't get puffed up with pride
don't think that don't be high-minded
about thinking oh I'm so much better
than somebody else because you have to
remember where your help comes from you
know
the Bible is saying don't be arrogant
thinking as as if God isn't helping you
God gave you gifts he gave you abilities
he gave you opportunities and
circumstances even listen to this
Deuteronomy 8 18 Moses had to remind the
people he said You shall remember the
Lord your God for it is he who gave you
power to get wealth that he may
establish his Covenant which he swore to
your fathers
now in Psalm 10 verse 4 it said the
wicked in his proud countenance does not
seek God
God is in none of his thoughts
the proud in heart
don't see their need for God and it's
difficult for the Holy Spirit to convict
them of their actual condition and their
need for God's Saving Grace so what I
love about the word of God
Bible if you look at everything it
defines humility as having the mind of
Christ to be totally dependent upon God
the Bible tells us in Philippians 2 5-8
have this attitude I'm reading from the
nasb I like this have this attitude in
yourselves which was also in Christ
Jesus who although he existed in the
form of God did not regard equality with
God a thing to be grasped but emptied
himself taking the form of a bond
servant and became obedient he humbled
himself to obedience to the point of
death on a cross
the definition of pride in the Bible is
when we don't depend upon God's sake not
all puffed up with pride and he sinned
because he no longer depend on God and
boy he proved Proverbs 16 18 that Pride
goes before a fall
so Joshua
be happy about your achievements just
don't get haughty and arrogant about
them amen very good very good
Daniel
your second question three-minute
question when will all eyes see Jesus is
it when he comes back or after the
Millennium and this is from Rosaline in
Florida all right thank you Rosaline for
asking this question here and it's a
good one because we want to know that
our expectation is based on God's word
so that we will not be deceived and
though we're ready when Jesus comes
you're referring to Revelation chapter 1
verse 7 which says behold he is coming
with clouds and every eye will see him
even those who pierced him so let me
take you now to Matthew 24 30 and you'll
find a few connections here then the
sign of the son of man will appear in
heaven Jesus is talking here it says
then all the tribes of the earth will
mourn and they will see the son of man
coming on the clouds there's that phrase
again of heaven with power and great
glory and he will send his angels with
the great sound of a trumpet and they
will gather together his elect from the
Four Winds from one end of the Heavens
to the other and so this is when the
righteous dead are raised and we know
that that is when Jesus returns coming
on the clouds in glory when all eyes see
him Matthew 26 64 Jesus is actually
before the Sanhedrin before he dies
talking to the high priest and he says
it is as you said nevertheless I say to
you Hereafter you Mrs the high priest
there one of the ones who is among those
who pierced him will see the son of man
sitting at the right hand of power and
coming on the clouds of heaven and so
once again the All Eyes seen him is when
Jesus returns and this is why Jesus
gives the warning about false prophets
who will try to deceive when he says if
they say to you this is Matthew 24 26
look he's in the desert do not go out or
look he's in the inner rooms do not
believe it for as Lightning comes from
the East and flashes so to the West also
will the coming of the son of a man be
now we get confirmation that Jesus
coming as the second coming will be seen
by All Eyes First Thessalonians 4 16
tells us that when he comes the dead in
Christ will rise first that will be an
unmistakable Visual and audible event
and then Matthew 16 27 Jesus says for
the son of man will come in the glory of
his father with his angels when Jesus
comes in the full Glory of his father
and all the Angels it just took one to
kill 185 thousand Assyrian soldiers of
sennekarib when all of them come nobody
is going to sleep through it or miss it
because they're gaming in the basement
or because their earbuds are in and they
didn't Fallout everybody is going to see
it and there will be only two groups of
people and they will respond based upon
the character that they have developed
they will either be cheering for their
best friend who they finally see in
person or they will be running
frightened from an alien from outer
space at least that's what they might
continue consider him so everyone will
alive will see Jesus when he returns now
after the Millennium all right those who
are the wicked Revelation 20 verses 5 to
9 says they will be raised again and
then under the leadership and deception
of Satan they will attack the New
Jerusalem the holy city and so they will
see him again then but what is referred
to in Revelation 1 7 is when Jesus comes
and regardless of the answer you and I
should be ready today for when Jesus
comes by a constant friendship with him
amen amen John your four minute question
in Revelation 20 verse 13 there is
mention of Hades or hell as well as the
story of the rich man in Lazarus does
this mean that after the P does that
mean after the people die they indeed go
to an alternate place and wait for the
return of Christ and this is from
Beverly in Zimbabwe
very good thank you Beverly I read to
you Revelation 2013 the sea gave up the
Dead who were in it and death and Hades
delivered up the Dead who were in them
and they were judged each one according
to his works so what happens when we die
we go to the grave and there are two
there are words that are used for this
in the Bible and you notice you
mentioned the word Hades now this is not
really an English word this is a
transliteration which means a bottle
borrowed a word from another language
and using it in the Bible and such as
you may have heard the word hors
d'oeuvres
you know these are words taken from
another language and used in the English
language but people know what hors
d'oeuvres are
and people know what Deja Vu is somehow
our knowledge comes from the youth and
so in the Bible the word Hades is used
and the translators did this uh in the
in the New Testament is the word Hades
and in the Old Testament is the word
Sheil which really means the grave you
are placed in the grave and you will
notice that as you look at the different
texts they use these words
both the good and the bad go down to the
Grave they go down to Hades so there's
no distinction made in these verses and
we're going to read some verses here
that will help you see that first I want
to say that there is no intermediate
State there's no place where you go and
you are sitting around doing something
or or doing nothing you are unconscious
you're not having any participation
you're not doing gaming like you
mentioned you're not playing Harps
you're not in heaven enjoying the Bliss
of heaven when you die you're in the
grave waiting the resurrection of the
righteous awaiting the resurrection of
the wicked let's go to Ecclesiastes
chapter 9 verse 5 and 6 really quick it
says for the living know that they will
die but the dead know nothing
and they have no more reward for the
memory of them is forgotten also their
love and their hatred and their Envy
have now perished Nevermore will they
have a share in anything done under the
sun this is until Jesus Christ returns
uh Psalm 115 verse 17 says the dead do
not praise the Lord nor any who go down
into silence so the dead they do not
praise the Lord some people have the
idea actually many people that if you're
a good person if you are righteous and
you love the Lord when you die you go
immediately to Heaven that's not what
the Bible says the Bible says that the
dead do not praise the Lord they are in
the grave in silence and so uh we have
the word Hades and like I said it's a
transliteration and you can go into
dictionaries and find out
that is the realm of the Dead the place
where people are and they are
unconscious they're just there and so uh
look at Acts chapter 2 uh verse 29-32
and this is talking about Jesus men and
Brethren let me speak freely to you of
the patriarch David that he is both dead
and buried and his tomb is with us this
day therefore being a prophet and
knowing that God has sworn with a note
to him that the fruit that of the fruit
of his body according to the flesh he
would raise up the Christ to sit on his
throne he foreseen this spoke concerning
the resurrect Resurrection of the Christ
that his soul was not left in Hades it
says this is a new King James version
and in the King James version it uses
the word hell which is uh uh very clear
there nor did his flesh see corruption
this Jesus God has raised up of which we
are all Witnesses so where do we go when
we die why before Jesus returns we go
down to the grave and there the person
is until the resurrection of the
righteous or the resurrection of the
wicked there are two resurrections Reach
Out John chapter 5 verse 28 and 29 for
more information amen amen good answer
good
Shelley
your second question I still get worried
about death how can I know that I will
be saved and this is from Martin in
Maryland Martin it's good for all of us
to
search ourselves John 1 12-13 says that
as many as received Christ to him to
them he gave the right to become the
children of God to those not born of the
flesh but born of the spirit my first
question to you have you been born again
first John 5 10-12 brings me great
Assurance let's look at the nasb first
John 5 10-12 the one who believes in the
Son of God has the testimony himself the
one who does not believe God has made
him a liar
first let me tell you the word believe
means to depend upon to rely upon it's
more than just a mental Ascent of faith
it is an act of faith that you walk in
obedience and he says if you don't
believe God you've made him out to be a
liar because he's not believed in the
testimony that God has given us
concerning his son and here it says in
verse 11 is the testimony that God has
given us
eternal life and this life is in his son
he who has the son has life he who does
not have the son does not
so let me ask Martin are you in Christ
if you are abiding in Christ walking
with him submitting to him then you can
have Assurance of Salvation because you
have the son are you keeping God's
Commandments first John 2 4 says that he
who says I know him it does not keep his
Commandments is a liar and the truth is
not in him and then I suggest oh
everybody should read Romans 8 at least
once a month
Romans 8 I'll look at verse 13.
Paul says if you live according to the
flesh you will die
but
if by the spirit you put to death the
Deeds of the body
you will live so you can't put to death
the Deeds of the body by yourself it has
to be by the power of the Holy Spirit
but the Holy Spirit doesn't force you to
do it so it has to be you who put them
to death by his power for as many as led
as are led by the spirit of God these
are the sons or the children of God you
did not receive the spirit of bondage
you get into fear don't have to sit ring
your hands and worry if you're in Christ
you're saved you receive the spirit of
adoption by whom we cry out Abba Father
knowing that he is our Papa and that you
are the spirit himself Bears witness
that we're children of God if you're a
child of God you are a coheir with
Christ amen I need men
I want to take about 45 seconds just to
submit a reminder again if you want to
submit your questions to uh to our panel
to our Caribbean family
if you want to text that number is
618-228-3975 perhaps you'd rather email
and if you want to email that's bibleqa
at 3abn dot TV and those that like
Instagram it's 3abn
underscore official so there you have it
we love getting your questions in Daniel
let's go to question number three
I have been baptized twice at age 14 and
age 23. under what circumstances do I
need to be baptized a third time
I had a child at the age of 25 and got
married at 26. do I need to get
re-baptized and that's Rhodesia in
Bahamas thank you rhonisha each person's
experience with Jesus is individual and
personal and you know we work together
we work accompanying each other and
strengthening each other but ultimately
it's the Holy Spirit who guides you in
the decisions that you make with good
Godly counsel we understand that baptism
is a symbolic action and near the
beginning of our Christian Life where we
declare that we accept salvation through
Jesus we recognize our sin we repent of
it and it symbolizes the forgiveness of
sin and beginning a new life with Jesus
and it's accompanied by education
learning about how to walk with Jesus
and making a personal commitment there's
one clear example in the Bible of
re-baptism and that's in Acts 19 verses
1 to 5 where Apollos has just learned
from Paul about the holy spirit that he
did not know before and this
foundational knowledge changes
everything about his relationship with
Jesus and so he is re-baptized with that
new knowledge that's the only example of
re-baptism in the Bible and so these are
the two reasons usually put forward for
re-baptism one of them is new knowledge
Vital Information that changes
everything or if you are returning to
Christ after having rejected him and
with each of these you making you're
making a covenant in this baptism to
walk with Jesus now for you I would say
talk with your pastor about it and pray
with your pastor and then pray about it
individually if you're feeling distant
from God and you recognize that you've
let things come between you and him and
you've been spiritually Unfaithful I
would ask you two things
number one I would ask you when was the
last time you celebrated communion
because communion is the experience
where after we've been baptized we
continue to come back to the blood of
Christ and accept that for our
forgiveness of sins for Christians it's
a periodic recommitment to what we uh
accepted what we declared and confessed
in baptism we don't get re-baptized
every time we sin every time we stumble
or wander but we return to Jesus and
communion is one of those ways that we
can do that first John 1 9 says that if
we confess our sins he is faithful and
he is just and he will forgive our sins
the ones that each ones of us have
committed we bring to him and cleanse us
of unrighteousness and first John 1 7 2
verses before says that the blood of
Jesus Christ his son cleanses us from
all sin so if you have an accurate
knowledge and understanding of the
scripture and you recognize I need to
return do that through communion begin
that and then participate regularly and
then the second thing that I would ask
you is have you been daily coming to God
by studying his word and prayer this is
how Christ interacts with his church
this is the cleansing process of using
his word to help reveal our sin and then
bring us back to his love listen to
Ephesians 5 26 in the context of baptism
that that Christ might sanctify and
cleanse her this is the church cleanser
with the washing of Water by the word
that's the study of the scriptures as we
let God's word reveal things in US
baptism in water doesn't itself change
you it just symbolizes what God is doing
in you but return to God's word just
like you eat your meals daily daily
daily and then talk to your pastor pray
and ask God about it amen amen well
Johnny
yes sir your third question can you
explain acts 21 25.
very well acts 21 25 I have to say that
there's a similar situation taking place
in Acts chapter 15. but let's go to Acts
chapter 21 beginning in verse 18 to get
a context of what is going on here it
says on the following day Paul went in
with us to James and all the elders were
present when he had greeted them he told
in detail those things which God had
done among the Gentiles through his
ministry and when they heard it they
glorified the Lord and they said you see
brother how many myriads of jewels there
are who have believed and they are
zealous for the law notice here but they
have been informed that you teach all
the Jews who are among the Gentiles to
forsake Moses saying that they ought not
to circumcise their children nor to walk
according to the Customs what then the
assembly must certainly meet for they
will hear that you that you have come
therefore do what we tell you we have
four men who take about take them and be
purified with them and pay their
expenses so that they may shave their
heads that all may know that those
things of which they were informed
concerning you are nothing but that you
yourself also walk orderly and keep the
law but concerning the Gentiles who
believe we have written and decided that
they should observe no such thing except
that they should keep themselves from
things offered to Idols from blood from
things strangled and from sexual
immorality this is a last verse is acts
21 25 which you are questioning about so
what how do we look at this these were
the Jews there's the one Jesus Christ
died the ordinances those laws that have
to do with sacrifices
and these things such as we read here uh
were done away with because Christ
fulfilled all the sacrifices no more
sacrifices are needed and they are
addressing issues the Jews had a
difficult time because a change has
coming and the change came through Jesus
Christ so they were having issues
concerning this is why they had meetings
about this but I want to say to you that
some take this to say that the law has
been done away with we do not have to
keep the Ten Commandments which is
incorrect because if it's just that hey
don't uh offer to idols and keep
yourself from blood and from things
triangled then that would mean that it's
okay to steal that means okay to kill
and uh to really ignore the Ten
Commandments but in Romans chapter 3
verse 28 through 31 the Bible says
therefore we conclude that a man is
justified by faith apart from the Deeds
of the law or is he the god of the Jews
only is he not also the god of the
Gentiles yes of the Gentiles also since
there's one God who will justify the
circum sized by faith and the
uncircumcised through faith do we then
make void the law through faith
certainly not on the contrary we
establish the law I encourage you to
read James chapter 2 as well and you
will see context that yes we should
continue to keep God's Ten Commandment
law amen amen
Shelley your third question is a four
minute question
in Mark 13 22 the word says for false
Christ and false prophets will rise and
show signs and wonders to deceive if
possible even the elect
the question we know that the elector
God's chosen people in the last days
will we need serious
we will need such serious people to
withstand The Wiles of the devil how do
we do that and how are we not to be
deceived Satan will bring forth such
lying deceptions to deceive if possible
evenly elect how do we guard ourselves
against the enemy wonderful question
this Mark 13 22 this is Jesus words
false christs false prophets will rise
he says and show signs and wonders to
deceive if possible even the elect let
me ask you how do members of the staff
of the Treasury Department How do they
identify a counterfeit they are trained
to know the original the real
so well
that if they see a counterfeit bill it
could be 99 percent right but they'll
see right away this is not a real bill
because this is off so what we have to
do is realize God's words are treasure
and Paul says to Timothy in second
Timothy 2 15. this is Amplified stutter
study and be eager and do your utmost to
present yourself to God approved tested
by trial a Workman who has no cause to
be ashamed correctly analyzing and
accurately dividing the word of Truth
you know he goes on to tell Timothy all
scripture is given by God it's
profitable for Doctrine for reproof for
correction
for instruction in righteousness that
the man of God may be thoroughly
equipped for every good work so what
would I say study study study we live in
a world that no longer likes to take the
time to read oh we've got to break
ourselves of that habit people have
developed because of the internet and
iPhones and chats and twitters we're
developing the attention span of a
hummingbird
we take a little sweetness here dip a
little sweetness here we can't do that
with the word of God it's line up online
precept up on precept
Paul told the Ephesians in chapter 4 and
verse 14 that we should no longer be
children being tossed to and fro by
every wind of Doctrine and the trickery
of men in the cunning
craftiness of deceitful plotting Satan
is out there plotting our deceit and
what we've got to do
is beware we have to you know he says in
second Peter 3 16-18 that some people
will read Paul's writings and they twist
the meaning to their own destruction are
some things difficult to understand yes
but he says in second Peter 3 and verse
17 beware lest you also fall from your
own steadfastness being led Away by the
heir of the wicked you cannot understand
a deceitful plot and identify it if you
don't you don't know it's counterfeit
unless you know the truth so he says
grow this is verse 18 second Peter 3 18.
I love it grow in the grace and
knowledge of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ stay in right relationship with
Christ do his will Matthew 7 21 he says
you won't go into heaven unless you do
his will and trust this First Peter 1 5
says we are kept by the power of God
through our faith for salvation to be
revealed in the last time Jude 24 says
now to him who is able to keep us from
stumbling to present his Focus before
the generation we know that the heart is
deceitful above all things so what we
have to do here it is James 1 21-22 lay
aside all filthiness and the Overflow of
wickedness receive with meekness the
implanted word which is able to save
your souls but be doers of the word and
not yours only that you deceive
yourselves thank you good man
Daniel your fourth question
can you please explain John 13 34.
new commandment and franks from
California sent that in all right
this is a great text the new commandment
is to love each other we should do that
amen the command to love seems so
obvious to us Christians how could it
possibly be new in fact we do find it in
the Old Testament the older Testament
Leviticus 19 verses 17 and 18 says you
shall not hate your brother in your
heart you shall surely rebuke your
neighbor and not bear sin because of him
you shall not take Vengeance nor bear
any grudge against the children of your
people but you shall love your neighbor
as yourself
I am the Lord and so this is a love
based upon I am the Lord based upon
God's identity especially in how we deal
with people how we deal with sin so when
Jesus was asked what's the greatest
commandment Mark 12 9 29-31 Jesus
answered and said the first of all the
Commandments is hear o Israel the Lord
Our God the Lord is one and you shall
love the Lord your God with all your
heart with all your soul and with all
your mind and with all your strength
amen this is the first commandment and
the second is like it you shall love
your neighbor as yourself there is no
other commandment greater than these and
so the new commandment in John 13 34
clearly must only be new to us because
it wasn't new to Jesus and it wasn't new
to scripture not that the people hadn't
heard it before but something about the
Commandment must have been new that they
had not fully understood yet we thought
we knew it just like we thought we knew
that uh if we were not to murder it just
meant not killing someone but Jesus
revealed it even includes your hateful
thoughts and so when Jesus gets to John
13 34 what is new or at least what is
new to us
it's a demonstration that goes deeper
and more personal and more intrusive and
more demanding than we thought possible
it's a demonstration through Jesus that
had been there all along with the
disciples and us had not been quite
ready or warmed up to see it yet
in John 13 this is the chapter right
before the night before Jesus dies
verses 14 to 17 Jesus says if I then
your lord and teacher have washed your
feet you also ought to wash one
another's feet for I have given you an
example that you should do as I have
done to you most assuredly I say to you
a servant is not greater than his master
nor is he who is sent greater than he
who sent him if you know these things
blessed are you if you do them
so here is the new part of the
Commandment it is the perfect living
example for us to follow because what
happened there in the upper room in John
13 climaxed on the cross
and this is a new thing a love so
complete self-sacrificing extended to
those who do not deserve it and do not
yet understand this was new
and so John began to understand this and
he certainly loved it and he then began
to tell us what love is we talk about
love so flippantly and foolishly I love
tacos love my car but First John 3 16
says this by this we know love because
he laid down his life for us and we also
ought to lay down our lives for our
brethren
hey man
Johnny yes sir your fourth question
some pastors say are they teach eating
meat even clean meat is a sin and those
who eat meat will not go to heaven
I'm confused didn't Jesus eat meat this
is from Nancy in Michigan
thank you Nancy and we hope to give you
something to begin your journey in
finding an answer
in Leviticus chapter 11. we see the list
and explanation as to how you determine
which animals are clean and which
animals are unclean and you mentioned
that some pastors are saying that even
eating the clean animals is a sin
we do not have a thus saith the Lord for
such a thing there's no scripture that
says eating uh
clean animals is a sin there is no such
thing so
this is then something that comes from
the person stating it and not from God's
word
so I bring to you Luke 24
in which you mentioned Jesus eating meat
it says here beginning in verse 40 we're
going to do verse 43 when he has said
this he showed them his hands and his
feet this is after the resurrection well
while they still did not believe for joy
and marveled he said to them have you
any food here
uh so they gave him a piece of a broiled
fish and some honeycomb and he took it
and ate in their presence so this is
after the resurrection Jesus of course
uh was he hungry potentially not but he
ate to help them uh because they're
they're wondering is this is is this a
is this really Jesus so he ate and they
remember how he used to eat and they saw
him eating and now
um they say oh yes now they're rejoicing
because this is Jesus so yes he did eat
meat after the resurrection he ate me
before he was crucified he ate the
Passover Lamb so do we have any
scripture that says uh it's a sin to eat
meat no we did not however we need to
eat meat we need to take into
consideration that our body is the
Temple of the Holy Spirit question is
the meat of today clean or unclean as
healthy as it was in Jesus day I will
say to you not but if you are able to
grow your own clean animals this would
be the best choice if you choose to eat
meat if you grow them and you have them
because getting them from the market
means you're getting them that have been
treated and injected with things to
preserve their health or to make them
grow faster and so remembering that your
body is the Temple of the Holy Spirit
you need to make some choices to protect
your health so by taking the animals
clean animals that are in the market
that perhaps have been injected with
these things you are taking a greater
risk of potentially getting sick but
again the Bible does not say that eating
clean animals is a sin so therefore
until we have a thus saith the Lord and
we don't have that in the Scripture it
is not a sin to eat clean meat yeah amen
Shelley your fourth question I was
having a discussion with my husband and
he said a child is made in love so how
can sin be present
he does not believe the text in Psalms
51 5. I was shaping in iniquity and
incended my mother conceived me he
thinks this was just an interpretation
of the King James version can you please
help me understand
Psalms 51 5 is sin present in babies
and how can I know that the King James
version be trusted here okay
I first want to just say this
your husband has a Precious Heart oh
that all babies were brought forth
in love
unfortunately that is not the truth but
can the King James version be trusted
absolutely the scripture I'm going to
read it to you from the new King James
it says
uh Psalm 51 verse 5 behold I was brought
forth in iniquity that's actually what
the literal translation but it means the
same thing shapen is an Old English word
and it's it's meaning the same thing as
you are developed in the womb and
brought forth I was brought forth in
iniquity
and
in sin my mother conceived me
you will find
the English Standard Version says the
same thing I was brought forth in
iniquity and sinned my mother Amplified
behold I was brought forth in a state of
iniquity which helps us understand
my mother was sinful who conceived me
and the Amplified says and I too am
sinful we're getting really close when
we to understanding that from the
Amplified version
when it says when David was saying
I was shapen or brought forth in
iniquity
he is referring to the Fallen nature
ever since Adam and Eve sinned
their nature was changed
you know I love second Peter 1 3 and 4
that says that we are given by God all
things exceedingly great and precious
promises and all things that we may
become partakers of his divine nature so
it is only we're born Genesis 5 and
verse 3 says that Adam
and Eve gave birth to children in their
likeness in their own image so what
happens is their nature was no longer
righteous it was fallen and we're all
born
in their likeness with the Fallen nature
is a baby sinful no but a baby has a
fallen nature left to his own devices
will that child sin yes
then he says in sin my mother conceived
me it doesn't mean that David was born
out of wedlock he was the eighth the
youngest of eight brothers had two
sisters and the act of procreation in
marriage
is a beautiful thing that was ordained
by God
so what is he saying here once again
he's acknowledging his mother's Fallen
nature the mother of David the wife of
Jesse was her name is not mentioned in
the bible but in Psalm 86 16 David
identifies her as a handmaiden a servant
of the Lord so she was a Godly woman but
she shared this Fallen sin nature so
this is the reason
why do we need to be born again
a baby is pure a baby's bat is innocent
as they come
but they've got that Fallen nature
and this is why you must train up a
child in the way they should go and take
them all the way to the cross and beyond
the Bible says in Romans 3 23-24 all
have sinned and fallen short of the
glory of God being justified freely by
his grace through the Redemption that is
in Christ Jesus amen amen let's take a
short break we'll be right back and
we're with some additional thoughts
if you're enjoying our 3abian Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3ab in Bible q a for answers from
God's word
welcome back do we have any additional
comments maybe final thoughts yes we
started with the Book of Joel and I'd
like to end with the Book of Joel
chapter 2 verse 13 says so Rend your
heart and not your garments return to
the Lord your God so God does something
inside and not just for show and then he
takes us back in time to Exodus 34 when
God revealed his character on Mount
Sinai to the Israelites after they
ascended the golden calf he says for he
is slow sorry he is gracious and
merciful slow to anger and of great
kindness and he relents from doing harm
and then in verse 32 Paul quotes this in
Romans 10 13 whoever calls upon the name
of the Lord shall be saved amen amen I
would like to share from John chapter 5
verse 28 and 29 do not Marvel at this
for the hours coming in which all who
are in the graves will hear his voice
and come forth those who have done good
to the resurrection of life and those
who have done evil to the resurrection
of condemnation amen amen all I want to
say is thank you once again for your
questions and we can't wait to next time
just want to thank you for spending this
time with us
just know how much we love you
appreciate you thank you for supporting
3abn
take care of yourself have a great day
God bless you
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign